well for one thing as a magician someone
who professionally deceives people but
does it for entertainment purposes I
know two things with great certainty
first how people can be fooled and
second and that's more important how
they can fool themselves and they do now
magicians know this and they allow
people to fool themselves but for
purposes of entertainment but I see the
charlatans out there they the people on
television to say that they can talk
with dead people I too can talk to dead
people but do they answer I think
Shakespeare asked a question like that
one time and Henry there's something
rather the point is people can be misled
into believing there is a supernatural
world out there now there may be I can't
say that there isn't but certainly what
is being shown us on television and
through the media in general by people
like John Edward for example and Sylvia
Browne and other performers like this
who say they have these supernatural
powers that is nothing like supernatural
powers there's nothing happening there
that the magician can't explain and
that's what got me so angry about it
because I saw lives being destroyed us
our money being taken I saw emotional
security being damaged desperately I
have people come to the James Randi
Educational Foundation in Florida they
sit in my library and they sit down they
say but our mother has control of the
books she has the power of attorney and
she's given all the money away to the
faith healer or to the fortune teller
the Gypsy or whatever and what can we do
and the answer is you can't do anything
if she's got legal control of it she has
a right to do what she thinks is right
with it now she's wrong in in that
supposition that is not what should be
happening in my estimation people should
be told the truth they should be allowed
to know that they Tam be deceived and
the average person out there doesn't
realize how easily they can be deceived
by a clever operator
well for one thing he he attained a very
high profile back of the 70s when he was
tested
that's her ego her we're talking about
who says that he can bend spoons with
his mind ah any fool can bend a spoon
but with his mind that might be a
different thing he attained a reputation
because he was tested at Stanford
Research Institute now after hours it
was informal the Institute had nothing
to do with actually testing him but he
was tested on the premises and that's
where that that impression was given
rise to eventually a scientific paper
was written up for a nature magazine by
the two rather naive scientists who fell
for the simple tricks that Geller did he
only has four tricks in his whole
repertoire for the last 35 years that I
know of and yet he's done very well on
them he said obviously made money in the
trade over those years and that's okay
he's making money as an entertainer but
he tried to tell people that he really
had supernatural powers that he came
from of all things and this is his words
not mine he came from a planet called
Hoover which apparently is a place where
they get vacuum cleaners I'm not sure
but he he said this this planet is way
out there in the solar system or beyond
the solar system and that he came from
that planet no he wasn't he was born in
Israel just like everybody else was in
Israel they born the same way of a
mother and a father
he didn't come from any mystical planet
nothing like that whatsoever
but the scientists who saw him and who
apparently tested him there she didn't
test him what they did if they allowed
him to do demonstrations of what he did
best
they wrote a whole book on him and and
they reported to nature magazine that it
was the real thing
well I objected to that and ever since
then I have been pursuing mr. Geller now
he has changed his tune he doesn't want
to be known as a psychic he wants to be
known as that mr. fire ho ho ho what
does that mean well it doesn't fool too
many people you see mr. Geller has a
problem his problem is that he cost
tens of billions of dollars in research
funds all over the world from countries
from companies from various corporations
and individuals and universities who
spent all kinds of money testing what
they called the Geller effect and they
wasted all that research money and time
and careers as well so if Geller now
comes out and says that oh I was only
fooling yeah that way that was a fib
that I told you I didn't really come
from the planet Hoover and I can't
really bend spoons with my mind that I
just simply do it when nobody's looking
is he well if you were to admit that I
think that the law would probably come
down on him pretty heavily certainly
some people out there would like some
recompense for their loss of time and
effort
oh well such things as free energy for
example zero-point energy getting energy
from no place that's we used to call
those perpetual motion machines but now
they're given a much more highfalutin
terms but that a lot of money is wasted
on that see we have a million dollar
challenge with the James Randi
Educational Foundation and that
challenge says do something that is
paranormal supernatural or occult and
you win the million dollars each thanks
the million dollars is there it's with
an investment house in New York City all
you do is perform as you see you can
perform and collect the million dollars
now mr. Geller has never applied for one
thing Sylvia Browne did apply she was
forced into it on a major television
show some years ago and she's been
looking for me ever since she apparently
can't find me she talks to dead people
and I'm alive and she can't find me and
I'm in the phonebook Sylvia what's wrong
but she says also that I'm not a godly
person now I would think that Sylvia
would think maybe I'll take this godly
person to the cleaners and take his
million dollars now it's not my million
dollars it belongs to the foundation but
it is a million dollars it's in
investible bonds that is cashable
negotiable bonds you can change it into
a million dollars overnight simply by
selling the shares that's all and so it
is there it's a million-dollar prize
that's a big turret to wave in front of
these people where are they they should
be knocking at that door right now as a
matter of fact I would think